[Music]
look at what is he [ __ ] doing hands
at 10:00 and 2:00 checking my mirrors
making sure everybody's where they need
to be oh it's a one-way [ __ ] oh I've
done this
oh it's somebody's mom god bless you god
bless your mom you know what she [ __ ]
up she realized it she backed up and
then she waved
this is classic look at this guy here
he's gonna have his ass in in my [ __ ]
lane then you beep at him and they don't
understand what probably because they
can't hear the thoughts in my head now
watch this now I go to take a left I
make sure I get my whole [ __ ] vehicle
in the left lane so some other [ __ ]
can pull up here okay here I am going to
make a left right I'm getting the [ __ ]
out there I want that guy in the blue
car to make it watch I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do this right now at least the
other guy he's gonna make it I actually
do this actually look at my rear view
mirror to see hey yo just open the
[ __ ] door don't look you can't
[ __ ] idiot if I took his door off
that's my fault
[Music]
everybody should just be banging a
[ __ ] right on red up here keep it
moving something somebody do [ __ ]
something you know what it is
there's no teamwork out here everybody's
like just out here for themselves you're
on a bicycle
I get it that's one less car in the road
good for you I'm behind you get the [ __ ]
over you're the first guy to make a left
get out there so there are other two
people behind you can [ __ ] it right will
you get out of my [ __ ] Lane you
[ __ ] idiot texting of course texting
texting texting why do I yell he can't
hear me you know last year's
[Laughter]